Can you tell me why you want to work for us?
Yes, I want to work for you for three main reasons.
The first reason is when I saw the job advertised, I was quite excited...
...because you have a really strong reputation...
...as being a market leader within this industry.
Now that's good for me because I have high standards...
...and I feel as your manager, you will support me to achieve my objectives.
The second reason is there are lots of really good reviews online...
...that are left by your customers.
So that tells me you always put your customers first,...
...you do things right, and again, you set very high standards.
The third and final reason why I want to work for you...
...is because you clearly have ambitious plans for the future.
I am somebody who doesn't want to sit still and just do the same thing day in day out.
I want to feel like I am progressing with the organization I am being a manager for...
...and clearly, that is the case with your organization.
So, I feel like I can come with you on your journey...
...and achieve consistent success moving forward into the future.